[Musique]
sur l'écran noir de
mes nuit
blanche moi je me fais du cinéma sans
pognon et sans caméra Bau pe partir en
vacances ma Vette c'est t jour
toi pour te dire que je t'aime rien à
faire je
flanche j'ai du cœur mais pas d''estomas
c'est pourquoi je prends ma
revanche sur l'écran noir de M nuit
blanche où je me fais du
cinéma
[Musique]
d'abord un gros plan sur tes
hanches puis un trbling
[Musique]
panorama sur ta poidrine grand format
voilà comment mon film
commence sourant je m'avance vers
toi
[Musique]
M80 des biceps plein les manches je
crève lesécand de M nuit blanche où je
me fais du
cinéma te voilà déjà dans mes
bras le lit arrive en
avalanche sur sur l'écran noir de
mes nuit
blanch où je me fais du
cinéma une fois deux fois 10 fois 20
fois je recommence la
séquence où tu me tombes dans les
[Musique]
bras je tourne tous les soirs
y compris le
dimanche parfois on sonne jour c'est toi
vais-je te prendre par les
hanches comme sur l'écran de mes nuits
blanches non je te
dis comment ça
va et je
t'emmène aussi
[Musique]